I just sent you a cheek swab. I forgot to mention, we did go to a biological dentist because
one of my causes on my initial cheek swab was dental. I haven't had a dental worked
out in my life except for a couple of pulled baby teeth and wisdom teeth. The biological
dentist did a panoramic CT and said he did not see any indications of infections or anything
wrong. So is there anything I could be missing as far as dental cause? No. So the cause,
the cause was dental. It could have been 15 years ago. There was an infection because
of the great things that, because I know who wrote this, the great things that you have
done over the years, you killed it and you're doing great. So that's, you know, you did the
right thing. This is the right thing to do. It's your biological dentist. If they didn't
see any infection, any underlying infection, then you're good to go. So you're perfectly
on the right track.